i'm going to spin the wheel now and
we'll continue our brilliant game
pat sage i could learn a thing or two
from the way i spin this wheel watch
look at that wheel go
yes it's the letter k
k all right gary let's get right to your
clue
all right do it start i'm timing it uh
uh easy
easy don't rush it don't rush it
this is a gary this is a tough one isn't
it i can you play the clip again
all right here's your clue all right do
it
start i'm timing uh easy easy
don't rush it all right that was clearly
ronnie's voice
hey is the clue i'll give you a second
clue how's that how's that gary
yeah here you go here's the second clue
i'm laughing my ass off it was great did
you get a boner
nah look at this here's the place look
at this i did i felt
you know you felt the boner yes i did
now you gotta know come on k is the clue
i don't know i can i really don't friend
fred can i phone a friend
no that's not this show i mean it sounds
like ronnie's getting something stuck up
his ass but i don't know how to apply a
k to that
well let me go to robin quivers you can
steal here robin do you know what k
stands for i'm with gary i'm not
really getting anything that would be
[Music]
for what i'm hearing come on fred you
must know
uh the letter is k correct i just want
to make sure the word
yes okay so we're starting with uh that
kissing somebody kissing something red
you're on the board with kiss that is
correct
this is the answer guy i got it no i got
it
too late gary you lose fred wins he got
k is for kiss and it's
when ronnie go ahead gary say it when
ronnie kissed lisa g
that's right listen again guys
you can hear the voice painful this was
unbelievable former howard 100 news
reporter lisa g said she would kiss
ronnie the limo driver if the stern show
twitter account
got 5 000 retweets what is the tweet
we're going to send gary so people know
how to find it if you want to see
lisa g make out with ronnie retweet this
let's see how long it takes to get to 5
000.
it took only a few minutes everyone
wanted to hear it all the fans of the
show
tweeted immediately
anybody need chapstick 47
what am i nervous about
[Music]
how much 4 800. now we've got 360.
[Music]
just listen carefully all right do it
start i'm timing
uh easy easy let's just get it when did
they start
don't rush it don't rush them
i'm laughing my ass off it was great did
you get a boner nah
look at this here's the place look at
this i did i felt you know
you felt a boner yes i did
fred if i remember the studio set up
correctly
yes didn't you have a perfect view that
was it was pretty amazing i'm surprised
she wasn't like screaming your ass off
but
as i recall it was a pretty involved
kiss too
oh yeah we thought they you know she
cheated but she really went in for the
kiss
oh yeah i think when i re i think tongue
was involved am i correct yeah
she was dizzy when she got away from
honey he's got very soft lips
was that gross to look at yeah
oh my god that was so much fun was it
ronnie you're a really good kisser robin
i have a question for you
what if we were on the air and i said
robin you need to make out with ronnie
the limo driver
how many retweets would we need to
receive
in order to get you to make out with
ronnie 100 million
100 million and you would then make out
with ronnie
what if i did all the tweets myself
he was a good kisser did he give you
some tongue
yeah a little just enough perfect